we've purchased this huge two thousand
seven hundred square meters building
with this huge seven and a half thousand
square meters of land and insha'allah
with your help we are going to convert
this huge property into the most epic
islamic center in the whole country of
norway now this is a sadhaka geria that
will keep on giving you rewards for as
long as this masjid stands click the
button to donate whatever you can
the the thing that i'm not clear on is
if god if allah is all powerful and or
loving
he is benevolent
then how how does how did those two
attributes how can you reconcile them
with free will because if he knows what
we're going to will then how how and and
we then we sin and ultimately end up in
is it johanna that hell yes then there's
something else
i think it was right originally the word
may have come from a rubbish sheep
outside jerusalem anyway so
so if he's all loving why would he
create beings which inevitably going to
end in johanna in the house
okay that's a good question so this
question actually muslims ask this
question as well
and it's a question where a lot of us we
kind of grapple with now i found i want
to say a formula but i found a way of um
because when a person asks this question
they are ridding their self of
accountability what they're saying is if
god knows where i'm going to go then
what's the point of me doing anything
and i'm like why don't we use that logic
the same way and say well if god knows
i'm gonna go paradise you know why is it
only with hellfire why do we apply with
the paradise so this is the way i kind
of found an answer to it because when it
talks about we're not we're competitive
yeah so we don't we're not determined in
the context that we just believe that
god is in full control only no we
believe god knows he has willed our
action yes and also we have free will
how they work together we don't know
it's a mystery we do not know but
check this out and tell me if that makes
sense
what's your name strawberry strawberry
that's a very unique neighborhood i
actually like it
[Music]
yeah that's my real name by the way yeah
that's my mi5 name
so okay didn't put it like this here so
strawberry
sorry
yeah yeah okay kelly my country means
come on
okay so kel is someone who believes he's
going to go paradise
strawberry is somebody who believes he's
going hellfire argument's sake you both
believe in god but you you're a
pessimist you're an optimist yeah you're
optimistic you have to personally
however
strawberry yeah believes he's going
hellfire but he argument's sake yeah
let's go with the jewish thing yeah put
it down for a second yeah he believes
he's going hellfire but he still sticks
to the sabbath
he still does whatever he needs to do
yeah i don't know what you guys think's
let me do yeah so he follows the
commandments yeah he follows the
commandments okay um i think you've got
a festival coming out with you guys
drink alcohol like you're gonna be it's
coming up soon yeah okay so he's doing
everything god tells him to do
gail is someone who believes he's going
in paradise
but he does none of the good deeds
now
both of you
if you stand in front of god
you as someone who believes go in hell
fire
and you've done all the things god told
you to do
do you think god will send you to
hellfire or heaven
again he determined that i do those good
actions
so yes but that was also determined and
if gao gao can be a blind optimist but
still commit acts of immorality but he
has no power over his will
so it's that is an interesting argument
but it only takes it back a step there's
still that okay
disclaimer we don't believe
that
we believe god has built our actions but
he didn't force us to do it we have free
will i made it very clear yeah
i tell them they don't listen every time
what i'm saying is free will and god's
uh predestiny they do not conflict they
conflict in our mind because we can't
grasp god work so i want to give this
disclaimer when i do this
[Music]
this is not
god forcing me to do it
he's willed it but i have chosen to do
and i'll do it again
and i'm going to do it again
so i can't come and say okay this is god
no i'm doing this however god has
wielded it so coming back to my question
because we can come to that you want to
make that disclaimer
when i do these actions
there is no one forcing me to do it god
willing it does not mean he is forcing
me to do it
and you said god he said god god's will
yeah but just before we go that i'm
sorry can we do not ask the question
because it will make a bit of sense
remember what i said to you you're a
pessimist he's an optimist yeah
he's optimistic
you keep all of god's commands would go
would god send you to hell fire or
heaven
well i would hope if i kept his commands
it would be heaven that's the idea okay
based on you you're an optimistic
individual you believe you're going
paradise why you keep none of god's
commandments and you're a sinner would
god give you would god give you heaven
or hell
well if i am an optimist i will go to
heaven no no no if you're up
no no no no no no you're thinking i'm
going paradise anyways i'll come here
all the things i like and i'll do i'll
go against all of god's commands
just because you think like that but
i'll go to heaven or hell no that
doesn't mean now the point that i'm
trying to get here is the following yeah
because i was thinking about this a lot
just because one might think they are
going to a certain destination if they
do not put in the work they are not
going
that makes sense so just because you
believe you're going hellfire but you
still follow the follow the course
commandments which shows what your
actions play a role in where you end up
i repeat again you're actually because
the people that ask this question of the
issue of if god knew they are ripping
their self off accountability they're
saying god knows where i'm going to go
what's the point of me doing anything
and i'm saying no hold on a second your
actions play a role regardless of where
you think god is going to take you why
did god instill what he wanted what how
he wanted humans to act he gave right
still he asked you to do it well i think
it was revealed wasn't it in the in the
quran and in the hadith
so coming back my argument the thing
that i was making here uh strawberry and
girl i'm actually bad with names but
that's a very unique that's uh
so therefore it shows us what
our actions play a role in where we can
go one disclaimer
in islam we believe is initially
the main thing is this you enter
paradise by the mercy of god
so no works you can do is you can't come
to god and say hey god look how
righteous i was you cannot pay god back
for what the eye the blessing of the eye
that you have so
in totality is actually god's mercy that
you went into paradise but does does not
mean that you don't do actions you do
actions because of who he is he's
deserving of those actions could you so
could you not have um uh so you're
saying that ignorance
uh if you are ignorance of the word yes
then you're exempt in some respect in
this life right you would have a test on
the day of judgment so if i was ignorant
but i lived a terrible life and i
indulged in the worst acts of immorality
i would still have a chance of getting
into heaven purely on the grounds that i
was ignorant of islam no because in
islam for example
i'm sorry for interrupting but um
what i understand in islam you believe
that everybody is born a muslim yes
yeah so we answered your question kind
of we have this belief that you have the
fitra the inclination to the belief in
one good we've purchased this huge two
thousand seven hundred square meters
building with this huge seven and a half
thousand square meters of land and
insha'allah with your help we are going
to convert this huge property into the
most epic islamic center in the whole
country of norway now this is a sadhaka
geria that will keep on giving you
rewards for as long as this masjid
stands click the button to donate
whatever you can